au conseil des ministres toujours un
projet présenté par claude malhuret le
secrétaire d'état aux droits de l'homme
sur l'exercice de l'autorité parentale
le texte doit permettre aux juges de
décider en cas de divorce ou de
séparation que l'autorité parentale
pourrait être exercée conjointement par
les deux parents s'ils le souhaitent
là encore le président mitterrand rats
prouver qu'eric admettent le projet de
claude malhuret concernant les enfants
naturels issus de couples vivant en
concubinage propose de simplifier la
procédure après séparation
aujourd'hui la loi accord de l'autorité
parentale à la mer seul même lorsque les
deux parents ont reconnu l'enfant
si ce projet est accepté il suffirait
d'un accord mutuel des parents devant le
juge d'instance pour que l'autorité
parentale soit exercée conjointement un
progrès par rapport à la situation
d'aujourd'hui parfois douloureuse pour
certains si on se pose sur le plan légal
je ne peux voir this ip mettons décision
scolaire c'est un exemple très classique
à toutes les décisions de congé de tous
tes décisions qui ont lieu la vie privée
dans la vie et de tous les jours de
l'enfant ne peut pas intervenir
le projet repose sur un accord mutuel
mais si les parents n'arrivent pas à
s'entendre que va-t-il se passer
qui sera responsable des grandes étapes
dans la vie de l'enfant retour à la
situation actuelle avec requête devant
le juge de grande instance
le père par exemple aura à prouver que
l'enfant est en danger moral ou
financier avec sa mère un problème qui
n'est plus marginal en 1987 en france
plus d'un quart des enfants qui naissent
sont des enfants naturels les cas